hello everybody how's it going hope you
are having a great
uh kindness start of your week um
so i had a very eventful day yesterday
uh definitely today too a lot of
sleeping today actually
but okay so um i'm pretty excited to
just go ahead
and um share one of galefun's
masterpieces because
i was just looking through his games a
little because
i think i was talking to someone about
his third book uh
over the weekend and i kind of just
wanted to go back and take a quick look
at
um just some of his games and um
i think this was this was my second most
favorite my most favorite one
is actually the one where he played
against dominguez
in 2013 um
the the feeder grand prix i think it was
but this one is uh when he played
against
um uh chris chuck
and i thought that was also another
really good one so
let's just go ahead and try to cover
that also if you see a ginormous hand
sanitizer behind me
that's literally right in front of my
door so i've been doing that
um as much as possible just trying to
leave it in front of the door so i just
remember to do it and oh i think hello
everybody hi steve
hi yaroslav have luck luckless
uh hi donald roddy tracy whoa
oh no i wasn't lost or kidnapped well
theoretically i was slightly lost
because i didn't know where my streaming
was going that was a little final
yeah that was a little funny um i
thought i was streaming on youtube but
then i got scared this was going on
twitch
and apparently it was not going anywhere
so that was fun
but anyways oh hi chesleep yeah
yep that was a very great game and so
most of you might
already know this game uh if you know
this game and if you want to throw hands
around be my like ta
feel free to do that i would love that
well a lot of different countries too
i've been to to portugal my brother
lives in england so i guess that counts
all right let's go ahead and look at
this game for a little bit
so um
go on this white um i think this is
nuts i mean the opening doesn't really
hold that's much
difference compared to well i mean
there's not like a novelty in it
from the third move that would be very
shocking and
um so from what i understand uh
christchurch chose this line because it
was the last round
and he wanted to go super um
super sharp in the opening and it kind
of makes sense when you want to play
sharp chromophils
is usually one of the first things that
comes to mind
so all right um
i mean from what i understand he had
played the c65 idea
earlier in the um earlier
i want to say uh with girlfriend but
i'm also pretty sure he played it with
other people so
i yeah it's a little hard to be super
precise when it comes to who played what
since everybody played everything with
everyone at this point
and that statement sounds very
professional um okay i'm saying a lot of
our countries surprisingly i was in
philippines 2011.
well i'm in usa now barcelona i kind of
lived there for a year
all right let's just go ahead and dive
back in
to gail fundraiser and
so everything super normal nothing's
nothing out of the ordinary so far
everybody's just developing so i just
want to take
like a quick minute and talk about this
position
because well this is a good position and
i think it's very important to be able
to actually
um identify well what are we trying to
achieve
so what what do you think well i mean
hold on if you know the theory you know
the theory so that's not that doesn't
we're not looking to uh to
learn the theory we're just trying to
understand the position
so let's try to um give that a little
chance
so right now um for those of you who
play this opening feel free to also give
me um
moves and recommendations but
specifically for those of you who don't
play this opening
what do you think is what do you think
white wants to do what do you think
black wants to do generally
um how like white
where do you think the pieces belong for
white and black
i think that's one of the most important
things to be able to identify
in any position especially in this type
of positions that
the center is still up for grabs
so
so i managed and some days um it's i
don't really choose where to stream it's
kind of
pre-decided by the club the unlike
generally uh just a psychology is going
to be streamed on youtube
whereas the latest classes or the king
and pawn warfare is streamed on twitch
um from it can be brought from twitch to
youtube so nothing um
there's nothing stopping us but do we
yeah i it's like we want to have both
twitch and youtube as much as possible
alright so i see an idea with e3 okay
make sense does the pawn is under attack
alright you want to get the dark bishop
out so i'm assuming
someone might be thinking f4 okay one
should play
queen sign should try to limit blacks
counter play in center i like that
good job pipe and jack so i see a move
debate between e3 or bishop
bishop e3 i'm assuming that's also
due to um this pawn being under attack
right so you want
you want to figure something after your
pawn uh well d5 actually doesn't really
work
i think just because you're going to
lose this pawn anyways
so let's not really go for that queen
takes tifa oops queen takes d5
and um i mean white still has a game
it's not like white is losing but i
don't think it's
worth it we shouldn't try to actively
put ourselves in a worse position
so i do agree with move e3 um
i don't think bishop e3 is that great i
mean it's definitely doable but then
knight c4
is one of the things to consider
uh or just castle and later on trying to
go something with knight c4
um so let's just go ahead and
go for e3
yeah i agree that white kind of wants to
play solid white's most likely gonna do
stuff in the
center slash queen side so black should
most likely be doing stuff
and center slash king side yeah
castle okay let's castle
now um now what do you think we should
do
it seems like black is getting ready to
play e5 right
um
so interesting it's not a race the
position is super
sharp already so we can just chill out
i mean i i mean kind of but at the same
time you don't want to
chill out too much because you don't
want your opponents to
get the chance to do whatever they want
so when you see your opponent wanting to
play e5
you could start considering something
with d5 that's one of the moves
uh what i think about the idea bishop b2
i think it's very interesting but it
doesn't help us
right now because right now the move e5
is coming up
so that's something to consider
um yeah so we should definitely
keep in mind about well
how to deal with e5 yeah so do we want
black to get the chance to play e5 or
are we just happy with
um well basically what are we trying to
do
let's see
uh
i'm seeing some ideas i kind of like
them but
at the same time i think it would be a
little bit more um
interesting so
the main thing that i'm seeing is the
idea with d5
but i think the problem with it is that
well you can play d5 but then knight
goes to a5
and now the c4 square is being kind of
bombarded
and yes you can try to play something
like knight to d4 to take even more
squares away and defend your pawn with
your bishop
but this this bishop is still kind of a
little unhappy but this is totally
playable nothing wrong with d5
however would we want this pawn to be on
e5
and we play d5 because like it feels
like if the pawn is on e5 and you play
d5
our e5 our d5 might be a little bit
stronger because there won't be any more
e6 to deal with it and if the if the
pawn
is already on e5 then it's kind of
blocking the bit shot
so that's something something else to
consider do we want to wait for e5
before we play d5
and so yeah that's another
um possibility
there are there were some suggestions
for e3 i don't think
b3 i mean it doesn't feel like there's
something like
humongously wrong with it but at the
same time
e5 and now if you were to play d5 now
there's this e4
and you don't yeah that's not gonna be
pretty
so we shouldn't play b3 if we want to
go for e5 to five yep it does get a
little bit messy i agree
so in the game galvan just went ahead
and played rookie one
i kinda just like the idea of rookie one
um
because you are not making like a super
um decisive move like b3
you're not really committing to anything
super specific
um a3 doesn't really make much sense
because
well it's not like a wrong move but it's
also not really going with the flow of
the position because knight beats four
is not really a threat
if not before it was a threat yeah a3
would make perfect sense
um
so with rookie 1
now we're well we already we're kind of
waiting to see what black does because
now if black plays e5 we go d5
and now we can do this e4 right and now
this bishop can try to come up here too
now this bishop looks a little um
funny so that would be ideal
we can throw in a b3 to completely make
sure this knight stays out there
and i really do like this position i
think it would be pretty awesome if this
happened
white just has much more activity
so
after rookie one great stroke is the
smart this is a very important game he's
not going to risk e5 d5 and getting into
a pleasant position
so in the game he went to a5 now
what do you think is the idea with a5 is
it just simply a move to gain more space
in the queen side
or does it actually have like a hidden
idea
it got really cool here
uh it's kind of funny whenever i start
talking and i look at peach's direction
because
as you probably remember his majesty is
sleeping right up here
very cute position he's um kind of just
opens his eyes and gives me like a tiny
huh and then goes back to sleep
i wish i was a cat
he's always either sleeping or last
night he started chasing his own tail
that was just hilarious i was on the
call with my mom
and i was facetiming her and i showed
him i showed her
peachy chasing his own tail it was just
actually a video dance instead of just
calling my mom
ah some ideas with taking more space and
activating the rook oh that's actually
interesting i think in long term that's
that sounds very interesting yeah but at
the moment do you think there is a
serious threat
or like a5 is just trying to give white
the chance to mess it up
okay i i like this idea you guys are
just
mainly considering that black is just
grabbing space
okay so what do you think white should
do
i agree if it were to play b3 a5 would
be pretty useful
yeah so i think a5 overall is pretty
sneaky and i really like it
so um yeah i think the idea of a5 is
very valid very um scary
well let me rephrase that not scary very
very sneaky
just kind of waiting for opponents to
kind of wait and mess it up i love that
it's great so um
we don't really uh as white we don't
really want to do much in the queen side
at the moment we want to kind of
take a minute and see how and how it
unravels
um so
not exactly queen b3 but i think when c2
is worth mentioning
because well to be fair queen c2
was played in a different game um
whose game was this oh uh rumbledini li
chao
and huntymonsisk 2010
so i believe this was played their queen
c2 and
if i'm not mistaken the game ended in a
draw yeah
and um it was interesting bishop and
then you just
get the center you go for the center and
it was a very interesting game but the
girlfriend chose
not to go into this line he really
wanted to
still keep to surprise and just play a
little bit more easy
um oh queen e2 i like that idea
still keeping the queen around uh you
might want to simply
try and uh get your bishop out
i kind of like that um keep in mind if
you use player to play d5 this is
still a mistake because you would still
lose your pawn
i think queen two two is a good idea but
i think galvan didn't play it because
like one year before this game
that quiz youtube was played so it was
still pretty fresh and
he didn't really want to do that
steve north that is a good question um
the problem is that white doesn't have
any um balance going on
for that sort of attack on the king side
so that's why we can't just start um
like a
super checkmate but i think we are
trying to i think with queen youtube
we're definitely trying to
uh after queen e2 black just played
bishop g4
so um if
we i think if black played something
like bishop
f5 then what do you think white would do
because now it's like i mean this is
still a very interesting position
black uh did the sneaky evil avoided
sneaky queenie two
nobody is really threatening anything
immediately but
both sides are kind of just waiting for
the opponent to mess it up
so that's why we should try to figure
out
how can your opponent mess it up well
first of all this is the only place
that's not
exactly developed and it can be
developed so it can go
three different squares so it's
important to try and make a decision for
black
which one where should black go with
this bishop so what do you guys think
and to be completely fair these are all
theories so if some of you know this
feel free to throw hansen in the chat
and help everybody else out too
but for those of you who don't play this
or this is a little out of
your areas of expertise i used to play
grandfather black
but just very briefly temporarily i
didn't really play it for years
so this this is not exactly an everyday
type of type of type of deal position
for me
so yeah i think the idea of bishop f5 is
pretty valid there's a g4 bishop e6 i
think all three of them
are worth considering but so which one
do you think it black should go for
i see a lot of bishop g4s interesting
oh i see one uh bishop f5
oh interesting let's try and dive a
little deeper
while i try to unfreeze myself
uh it really started to get cold out
here
um okay so
um all right let's take it
first of all let's start with bishop f5
so bishop five is not the best
idea because well to be fair bishop is
kind of
hitting blanks and as white
you could consider two moves either
first of all d5
or first and or rook d1 would idea d5
for example a4 now you push d5 and then
as we've seen a little before this idea
with knight d4
and um this kind of feels pretty nice
right knight c4 and i think this is a
pretty pleasant position
for white
and all right um so this was a game
that happened with galefland ii this was
a game in um
yelp on top of 2011 but
this or this at the moment feels much
more comfortable for white
uh because white can just try to
play something a long lines of a3 or
sorry
rook b1 try to push for b3 or
let's go back there we go or something
just like queen c2
and putting more pressure on this pawn
so white has a lot of options and black
already has some weaknesses the best
thing about black solution is this
knight
which is not dead permanently oh i see
some farsi in the chat interesting
all right so we see why bishop f5 is not
the most popular choice um
what about bishop to e6
what do tango white should do now
so to be fair white has many other
like many many um alternatives so it's
not just
one move that white can do or can't do
but
some of these moves are for example a3
for example
knight to d2 or um something with
rook d1 as we saw in the previous one
yeah thank you
rick d1 and uh the only thing to kind of
keep in mind is if you were to play rook
d1
then bishop c who are attacking your
queen you gotta play something like
queen scene 2
knight b4 and now what do you want to do
with your queen
so harry i think you're correct and we
will we will be looking at bishop g4
briefly because bishop g
we're kind of looking at bishop jupiter
last because that's actually what
happened in the game
so now what do you want to do with your
queen
i kind of think queen b1 is kind of the
only move unfortunately
because yeah you can try something with
like queen e4
but then they're like c6 or there's e6
and your queen is very misplaced up here
so queen b1
is the best choice and right now as
black
e5 is very very very interesting
so now what do you think white should do
after this e5
i see everybody is kind of going towards
queen b1 anyways
funny captain doll um
well bishop d3 right now is not a threat
because he would take it
and we would love to take two pieces for
one rook that would be like the dream
so what do you think we should go for
after e5
so i see one idea with b3 interesting
and if b3 then takes on d4
if you were to take it back then bishop
can move away
and you have isolated pawn and your rook
is a little um
just kind of weird here
this is playable but black does have
pretty
black has a better game i think black
actually i can
uh we can yeah we can say
black does have advantage sorry
but yeah this is this is uh easier for
black to play
two bishops open center open targets
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at
is there anything else to do after e5
i think taking james i think you're
correct taking you at least we
definitely should consider it
um levy i where do you want to play
knight d5
um something about knight takes d4 i'm
assuming you are mentioning if
b3 then take you wanted to take with the
knight
well the problem is now bishop d3 gets a
little scary because
now uh there would be this c5 and your
knight is pinned
and we do we don't really want to to do
that we want two
pieces for rook we don't exactly want to
have to deal with just um
one piece for the rack you know
this is this would be better for black
already
so if in this situation you kind of have
to take it to the pawn
and you would kind of have to be forced
into this position
as well and it's just not really
pleasant
let's see was this a game um
i think this was
this was a game and uh mcnabb
um the duke the jewish
oh my god i am horrible with
pronunciations
uh but this game was played in 2010
hunting monsters
and anybody who knows me you guys don't
grow with pronunciation so
i apologize for that but
i can't really do much about it besides
it for my english which i'm trying
but it will take some years before my
pronunciation is better
but alright any question in this line
with b3
and take take
yeah i think i think you guys are kind
of warming up to the idea of taking
right now
but the problem is kind of like after
take
uh queen takes d1 knight takes c1 and
bishop d3
and you're kind of your queen is kind of
getting trapped which is kind of funny
right
painful but funny
trying to see if that was mentioned in
the chat
so i'm gonna wait like a few seconds for
everybody to kind of catch up
and the questions to pile up before we
dive in
uh to answer the question yourselves
yeah you were right c5 was there yep
um harry i could you please remind me
which position are you talking about
after a3 ed
um where a3
um i'm assuming instead of b3 whoa
there's a question of a3
so i guess here a3 um
it's possible but if take
take on the here and taking on c3 is
is still possible because rook d1 still
exists and you can't really move your
bishop anywhere
bishop d2 i just take it if you were to
play a queen to c2
now there is again take here and b3 is
coming
and this is a very very scary position
for white
oh i see a miller you wanted to do this
atheist to prevent all this ah
genius wow
yeah i think this a3 would uh at the
this moment would be pretty painful to
be honest like yeah you can try knight
d2
but then just take and yeah if
to be honest this i this is a very scary
end game
to want to play um especially
with ooh these pawns and this bishop
yeah i don't want to play this i won't
i'd rather go to a
haunted house
oh i think this was actually a game that
caruana played as black
this makes a little more sense too yeah
um karana played this game
and his opponent played queen d1 right
now which was a
humongous blunder this is a game between
um lately and
caruana and contempt 2010
interesting and apparently tyranna only
took five minutes for the whole game
oh boy that must have been painful for
white so
queen d2 is a possibility with idea that
queen d2 you're just kind of
naturally giving that chance to um
queen d1 is a blunder because if queen
d1 just bishop b2
so queen d2 would be more logical but
still kind of painful
i really don't want to play this
position it's just a very painful
position
you're just defending left and right and
this is just super winning okay so let's
go
way way way back way way way way back
but it
did it did get pretty interesting i hope
that positions comes up in the thumbnail
all right so we were somewhere around
here and we were asking okay if e5 what
should we do
i agree yeah practically that endgame
white would definitely lose at least
seven out of ten
yeah i was also slightly surprised that
this line was played
yeah queen b1 does not look very
pleasant i agree with that as well so
let's just go a little back
so after e5 to be totally honest um
taking does not work as well so
most likely b3 would be the way to go
but b3 is also still pretty painful
take take and we would get to an
um to a little unhappy position
so that's kind of why bishop e6 would
have been
the best way to go and um
bishop e6 what white could do
is if you played rook d1 as in the game
with bishop c4
um you don't really have to play queen
c2 because as we saw queen 2 comes with
knight b4
and queen b1 kind of makes it a little
hard after e5 so you could just play
something with queen e1 it's not really
that pretty
to be honest not before still exists
with the idea of jumping to c2 and
making it more painful
but i think it's worth a try
um another way to think about it if you
don't really want to play
rook d1 i guess um
what about a3 now just to stop these
ideas
still a four and now this knight will
jump around here
so that also fails
uh maybe knight d2
yeah maybe knight d2 to keep these pawns
here so you're keeping your squares
but also at the same time you're
protecting the
the c4 square there it is yeah knight
the tukan stops it opens up the bishop
you are getting some ideas with d5
ideally you still are gonna try and play
this rook d1
but hopefully maybe like a knight e4
so there are a lot of things to be done
but knight d2
seems to be the most interesting one
instead of rick d1
what about b3 right away interesting but
still a4 yeah
if a4 if you were to like take take
take take now this trip got activated
well it's not like too activated because
still kind of um stopped but
now this is another target
so i don't i wouldn't want to play this
as white i would want to play this as
black
kind of black's pieces seem to have more
activity than whites
and i don't think that would be ideal
for white
yep so knight d2 would be the best way
to go in this position
however black did not play bishop e6 he
went for bishop g4
white simply played destruct sorry this
h3
kicking the bishop bishop goes back to
e6
and now um
from what i understand please feel free
to correct me but
in this position white simply played
b3 which is a which was a novelty at the
time
um the other ways to go about it was for
example knight to d2 or rook to d1
however if rook d1
i think bishop c4
is the way to go and they would kind of
get to the semi
same ish position either with a4
or like queen c8 or
um trying to see can e5 be
i think e5 right now doesn't work
because of the pawn on h3
the king does have a leeway
take that take that
take that and yeah this does work
actually take it with that because
this chuck doesn't work as strong since
the king can just run away
anyways let's go back back back back
and i wanted to talk a little bit about
knight d2 so knight d2 what do you think
black should do
bishop civil war is interesting but i
wouldn't call it the
i wouldn't call it deadly
so miller which position are you
considering
and um no i'm not i'm not streaming live
from iran i live in san luis missouri
uruguay center's chess club haha
let's see
some ideas about stuff i agree with that
um i still don't want to play b3
right away um oh okay after extra yeah
i agree after h3 it kind of makes a
little bit more sense
knight d2 is definitely playable but i
think the problem um
well i think this knight before would be
a little interesting as well because
knight's going to c2
and now after d1 queen c8 this is
another way to go about
it um this is still a pretty fight
you can try a3 that guy can move away
but this pawn is still under attack
you can take that maybe
if take with knights just king h2 defend
your pawn
so i do like this position i think white
does have a pretty good fighting
similar as black i think the only change
you can see is what to do with this
bishop to be honest
and e4 could also be coming up i do like
this position
all right so let's go back to the main
line knight d2 is pretty
possible rook d1 is possible after h3
but b3 was uh if i'm not mistaken
uh like home preparation from gelfand so
i think that's
worth more and after b3
black simply played a4 now
what do you think white should do well
we shouldn't take that that's the first
thing no taking
what else
um keith could you please remind me
which position are you mentioning
i am looking at the chat yeah that's the
chat is right here
on the lovely ipad which is kind of
running out of battery
um yeah
but i do have to say i'm very happy with
the participation tonight
it's just really great i think tonight
is one of the busiest nights with
uh in terms of comments and the
engaging and i think it's really great
to thank you everybody i see a lot of
new names i see
a lot of um familiar ones from
previously i order a twitch channel so
huge thank you for everybody but what do
you guys want to do now
we still got to finish up this game
which is a very long game
uh i'm actually playing this weekend i'm
playing
uh european women's club cup
i agree let's go rp1 let's save this
rook from trouble
no pinning i like it let's go uh
if take we take back in the game black
played queen c8
going after h3 whoa i double clicked
king h2 defending my pawn i don't like
to give up on
g4 is possible but it doesn't really
it's it's two it's too early
king h2 makes but stance this stroke a5
that was mentioned
much much earlier after some after black
played a5
someone mentioned maybe rocket by rick
h5 there you go here is your rookie
fighter h5
um so
all right okay fine
now um he now black can simply
it's kind of like trying to form some
sort of an attack to be honest
but um white doesn't really have to
worry too much about it
so first of all white could simply try
and play knight's p5 to stop this
or as it went in the game rook d1 is
another way to go
so rook d1 i kind of really do like the
idea of rooftop i'm kind of ignoring you
i'm like i want to play my d5 i'm just
activating my
rook what do you want to do i kind of do
prefer this to knight b5
and now in the game black played rook
h5 now why to move what do you think we
should do as white
you kind of know what black is going
after so
um oh great i'm glad you like this malik
um yeah i do
teach different classes for the club
i think this is the only one on youtube
then i teach a bunch of them on you
on twitch so feel free to check those
out too
uh steve
i don't think white's position is too
weak it's like
yeah definitely it is surviving and um
i don't think surviving is the right
word they just
black black has very few ideas that's
already trying out and white is kind of
waiting for the right moment to to
unleash in the center
and that would be pretty deadly so it's
just about the timing of it
oh i see a lot of different ideas with
h4 knight moves i don't really like
knight g1
knight h4 is the best way to go about it
bishop f6
and one more super strong move from
white what do you think white should do
and i agree i don't think h4 is a good
idea because bishop g4 existed
so why to move what do you think we
should do
oh i see pawn g4 i see an idea with
bishop f3
which you have to read is considered
worth considering
but um
the problem with bishop f3 is rook takes
h4
and yeah just take back take on h3 and
white starts to get kind of a little
unpleasant
so for that reason we don't really want
to
give that chance to black and that's why
we don't really want to go for bishop f3
this is a this move is kind of a very
interesting move
i'll give it another few seconds maybe
someone will come with us
no e4 is still too early still you can't
play e4 your d4 is falling
d5 still too early your c3 is still
under attack
oh no we like our bishop we don't want
to take it there then h3 would be super
weak
nope oh very surprised nobody's saying
this move huh
well the best way to go about it is oops
is f4 now
f4 kind of stops this e5 forever
and to top that taking on h4 doesn't
really work as well
because you just take back if rook takes
now you have a
super cool move of queen f1
also to top that king g3 is also an
interesting move
imagine if you can play king g3 and
still have a great move
you can imagine how great that this
position is for white
uh queen f5 queen f1 however is a little
bit just
more i won't say classy because queen f1
kind of stops everything
and now white could simply start going
at it in the center d5 coming
this bishop is no longer here to attack
so you can just unleash the center and
white is actually pretty pretty
pretty much better now um
so bishop takes that short doesn't work
black in the game played rook d8
and what do you guys think white should
do now
to be completely fair a move such as f5
is definitely worth considering
but we it's it shouldn't matter that
we're losing upon in this position or if
bishop takes h4
but i think it's very interesting to try
and find a very
interest very safe but at the same time
sneaky balance between when to push up
by
when not to push and i think this move
is that
because white played queen to f2
still going like preparing for f5 but
also supporting the knight a little bit
also supporting d4 a little bit
so i think queen f2 is that perfect
balance
i know right this bishop is still on c1
while we're doing all this
f5 would have been possible bishop d7
then you could try to like push over
there a little
taking on h4 and i
i just don't like the idea of giving my
opponent i don't like giving black too
many chances to
to take over stuff so i wouldn't really
do this
to be honest i kind of like queen of two
i like to keep it sweet and spicy
black played tank okay take was a
mistake
black should have actually played
rook back to a5 yep it's very weird but
that's what black should have done
but taking on s4 now white's just how
gonna have a blast
you take that guy back but and now
you're considering to
you know really unleash in the center
black played knight to d5
take take and
now well at the moment white can't play
e4 but
we can easily prepare for it right we
want to play e4 we can't because rook
takes d4
so how do we defect how do we um
protect d4 it should be two
right makes sense you just have to kind
of be uh be able to ask yourself the
questions of
what to do now what now what now what
does my opponent want how do i stop it
so bishop b2 is the way to go
um and
after bishop b2 i think white played
rook b5 which was another mistake
because for example now e4 is coming up
keep in mind that whoops ah no the wrong
way
that yes theoretically we could take
over here
and win some material but bishop takes
back and now this bishop
ah the ship gets too strong and
white does not want that so that's why
we didn't take
bishop b2 we want to just push on e4
it's kind of funny that black is like
putting a stroke against me i'm like nah
i don't want to eat that trick
queenie two going after this guy
going back on h5 because if you were to
take
now i have d5 and your bishop is getting
worse and my bishop is becoming a
monster
so rook goes back to h5 and
now after like 20 something 25 moves we
get this move that we wanted with e4
now d5 is coming up right forking and
everything
yep exactly i'm kind of glad you guys
are answering each other in the chats
too
yeah we don't want to give up our light
squares funnily enough
if you take it i have king g3 which is i
think such an
awesome move attacking the rook and we
still want to do d5
i mean seriously if you win with a move
such as king g3
it just it should show you how your
grades how your position is grades
how great your position is there we go
that's the right english way to talk
that's the right way to talk english
geez i've been watching a little too
much farsi stuff i should stop
so bishop takes b3 happened in the game
white goes
right c1 right we don't want to lose our
pieces while we're attacking
and you still are going for this d5
still opening up your bishop
black in the game went for knight to a5
now what do you think white should do
these are the last few moves of the game
which is very interesting
so what do you think white should do
we've talked about this reaching this
position for a while now
so now that we're here
so
so what's now
well your rook on d2 wouldn't be doing
much euro can see one is actually doing
something making some sort of an attack
oops yeah exactly d5 awesome
opening up your bishop your monster's
bishop
in the game uh christian played b6
position is getting a little helpless to
be honest
bishop e5 attacking this
imagine if your rick was on d2 you
couldn't do that now you're going after
this pawn too
uh blackboard c5 and
white played on poisson didn't really
have to
queen b5 would have also been super uh
strong
because you can just you know eat this
pawn too
so taking on c6 makes sense
as well
and here actually c7 is worth
considering
two but galvan just wanted to play it's
normal he went bishop all the way to a1
surprisingly because i'm also assuming
that if he could just take on v3 and
give this check and pick up this knight
that would also be super winning and i
don't think he just want he wanted to
avoid complications
in my and my um in my mind
and so when christian played troops
when restrict played drug c5 that kind
of stops the plan momentarily
take take but to be honest i think
taking here is
still worth considering but
we shouldn't really i mean if you see a
more an easier way to win you shouldn't
go for the more complicated one so if
you see one a way
to keep your pawn then you should do
that because the opponent's e6 is very
valuable but if you don't see any way to
win this is another way to try and
consider it
but let's go back to the game
take take and the girlfriend just simply
went
queen to b5 well rook g1 would not be
threatening anything
because then you would have to move your
bishop and try and create something with
the pawns
where the white scheme is mainly in this
center slash queen side and trying to
create some chances with the bishops
so it's a little bit of different
dynamic
so right queen b5
the game is getting spicy queen c7 and
now what do you think black
what do you think white should do
these are last few moves of the game
like literally two three moves left
keep in mind queen c7 is technically
defending this knight attacking this
pawn
and technically your c6 pawn is also
under attack
um i don't think queen c6 would have one
because
i mean if queen c6 as white you can just
take that guy
i'm assuming dirt b3 would also work
so queen c7 ah exactly let's take the
exchange well let's give up well not
really exchanged you're taking
um the b3 but if you were to take it
back i would just take it with check
and i would also get to keep my c6 pawn
so that's kind of what we want to go for
we want to be able to get those uh two
pieces and keep our pawn
in the game uh gristrix simply played
knight takes e6 and well
kind of gave up the piece which was very
interesting i guess
black white simply will goes e5 opening
up the other bishops stopping queen f4
ideas
um knight d4 and um
did queen c4 check i'm assuming bishop
d4 is coming up as well
b7 is coming up as well a lot of things
are coming up
none of them are very pleasant for black
and um yeah at this moment
segrestruck resigned
and i think that is how girlfriend
became the
one the um
okay i don't want to say the wrong word
give me one second
exactly the candidates and kazan
okay that's what i wanted to say um
world champion candidates yeah the award
wasn't coming up
but yeah so that's how grease trick won
this candidate tournament
and 2011 and i think that was actually
pretty cool to
see that because it was such an up and
down game we saw how it could have gone
wrong for
black uh or how could have gone wrong
for white actually
and how black tried to uh make it work
but it was kind of too late at that
point
and the idea of rk5 rk5 i really liked
that i think that was interesting
but it just wasn't really enough and
along the way
black made some mistakes as well
um for example queen c7 here was a
mistake
like bishop a2 was better let's look at
another example
um a little bit earlier with like the
rooks moving around
when the rook was on h5 so whoops that
we got lost a little in the position so
after f4
d8 queen f2 taking here was wrong
uh it would have been more interesting
to just pack and leave the stroke
so yeah that are the black
the bottom line is that black made more
inaccuracies and more mistakes than
white and that's kind of why white won
and surprisingly gmp she did not make
any appearances it's not
staring at me but she stayed away the
whole time
well i think that's the first all right
with that
i think i am going to go ahead
and um start wrapping up the stream
i still have a about 50 more pages to
read for my biochemistry
but um i am doing latest night this week
on twitch
thursday so feel free to stop by
thursday on twitch or friday on twitch
[Music]
if not i'll just see you right back here
next tuesday
have fun with the rest of your week